hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
our prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's going to go
but let's see
and previously we looked into how do we
get water on the land and we had a few
options one collecting the rain water or
drilling a very deep borehole and the
third option was that we found this
abandoned well on the neighbor land
so underneath here there is a natural
spring where they build a well on top
and it's not used anymore so we left it
that we should get in touch with the
neighbor to see if we can actually use
it and clean it up and he we got a reply
he said yeah you can use it which is
great
so in this video we're gonna
clean it all up to make sure it's
actually usable to double check
and if it is clean it and install a
watering system and we're going to start
by just cleaning up this area around it
which is fully overgrown to make sure we
can access it properly
[Music]
so you might think why we dropped down
these trees two reasons one is we have a
big tractor coming that needs to lift up
the lid from the well and put it
somewhere so we need place for the lid
and the tractor
second our land is full of these trees
which is called the mimosa and it's a
non-native species so it's not from here
and after the fire this is the main
thing that grew back but it's not a good
tree to have because it takes over
and it grows so fast that other trees
are not able to come so
the more of these trees we take down
actually the better it is for the region
because it helps other native trees to
come like an oak or a chestnut
so looks rough chopping down all these
trees but
should be better in the long run
so as i was cleaning this up i actually
noticed there's a small lid in the lid
that i might be able to take off by
myself let's see
[Applause]
wow
i wonder how deep it is
so i wasn't aware that was the smaller
lid so i thought we needed a bigger
machine to lift up this thing to go
inside
it looks like now i can actually go
inside like this
and i'm kind of curious to check it out
so
[Music]
[Music]
wow
that is deep
now touching the button so let me show
you how deep this is
[Music]
so that is about eight meters of food
depth
and it's around
380.
so the water is 4 meter 20.
so it's now mid of summer uh
quite a lot of water which is good we
were actually not sure if the spring
would give enough water but
it looks pretty good
so yeah unfortunately our long ladder is
not long enough to actually go in i
would have really liked that
but maybe later but at this point it's
also not really needed because i know
how deep the well is and how deep the
water is so i can start working on the
pumping system and getting all the parts
and meanwhile we're still waiting for
the guy to come to actually open up the
lid and clean the well
to take out all the dirt and disinfect
it
so the guy that comes to open up the lid
wasn't too impressed with my cleaning
job of cutting the trees
so he came with his digger and made a
bit more space now what took me an hour
he did in like five minutes
a bit rough but i guess that's how it
goes around here
[Music]
[Music]
once there was some space he opened up
led exciting moment also looks a bit
scary having this super heavy concrete
lid that it doesn't fall into the well
but and then i had to remind myself the
reason why these things are round or
even manholes in cities is that a round
object cannot fall in the tube so if
they were made square then it could fall
in so it should all be good
alim
ah
[Applause]
so i was working on the pump system and
it's super hot and i kept having in the
back of my mind there's a well right
there with super cold water
so i was thinking the ladder wasn't long
enough but that is because we put it in
the middle so it needs to reach the lid
but now it's open so maybe we're able to
just put the ladder to the wall and then
we're able to climb down because i'm
still very curious to see what's on the
bottom
so i'm going to give it another try
putting the ladder in and going down
there
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'll be honest this doesn't feel very
solid
but it also feels like what's the worst
that can happen you fall in a pocket of
water
i think we should just give it a try
this one is for you youtube
all right
[Music]
all right time to go
and look super cool okay a bit dirty
and on the bottom you can see some very
old rocks so it must mean it's a very
old well
and i think here is an overflow tube and
there's some sort of cave down here
looks cool but also that is
so that was super fresh so i convinced
ian to do it as well let's see
oh [ __ ] ah this sucks so much
oh
oh you like gold things no
oh
so now a few days later the guys come to
clean the well
and first they will empty it with a pump
and then they go down in there
and the people here work very safe and
there's a high risk of fire at the
moment because very dry
so he's smoking a cigarette above a
cherry can of gasoline okay
time to get started
and meanwhile the pump is running a few
beers to get ready for the job and once
the well was fully emptied
time to go in and rita convinced the guy
to wear the gopro we actually got from
you guys thank you on his hat so we can
see what it looks like down there from
his perspective
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
uh
hello
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so finally the well was cleaned and just
needed to put the lid back on also here
safety first
[Music]
all right so the well is now all cleaned
up uh we should be able to get the water
soon but we need to let it rest for a
few days so the fogginess in the water
can settle down
but either way we still need to set up
the whole pumping system and all the
tubes and connect it to the containers
which we're going to do in the next
video see if you want to like to see how
that's going to go make sure to
subscribe or come back next monday when
the video is released thanks for
watching see you in the next video